elektra ne voit pas le jour où elle
pourra enfin visiter ses parents
atteints de l'aco vide
la situation est à ce point hors de
contrôle au ch et celle des vigies
mont-royal qu'ils n'accueillent toujours
aucun projet dans c'est pas facile ça
fait deux mois que je n'étais pas
capable de rentrer fait que c'est
vraiment diriger pour moi mais je suis
sûre pour les autos c'est là que vit
donné par ni aucun résident dans sept
établissements privés conventionnés 226
aînés ont été déclarés positifs au moins
70 sont morts et près de 150 employés
ont été infectées mais membres sont
touchés les résidents sont touchés c'est
une question de santé publique et
j'avais l'obligation quand vous
connaissez une situation je peux pas
cautionner une situation comme ça moi je
suis obligé de la dénoncer l' enquête du
suisse a révélé la semaine dernière que
le système de ventilation était
défectueux et que le virus était présent
dans l'air
la ventilation a été réparée elle
pourrait avoir contribué à la
propagation du virus sans toutefois être
la principale cause les données les plus
récentes le semble démontrer que sera ce
coq d'or aura une capacité plus élevée
de persister de demeurer actif dans les
aérosols
donc ça devient passé bas ce moment là
que le système de ventilation et un rôle
à jouer là-dedans mais je pense que
c'est pas le facteur principal même j'ai
eu beaucoup peut-être d'employés qui ont
actuellement un malade etc
on pense aussi que la question de
l'hygiène du lavage des mains une
opération de décontamination est en
cours dorénavant le personnel et les
soixante six militaires déployés en
renfort doivent porter un équipement de
protection exceptionnelle qui inclut un
masque n95 une jaquette imperméable et
un capuchon uniquement protection
individuelle est extrêmement fatigant
extrêmement chaud à santé publique de
montréal a ordonné l'entretien des
systèmes de ventilation de tous et ch et
celle d ici genève garon radio canada
montréal